[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right just when you thought your
daddy could not get any better big box
look look this is something I don't know
how long I've been joking about this if
this is what I think it is this is proof
that dreams come true is this really
though I'm hoping this is proof that
dreams come there's no
is that really painting there's real
texture of like brushstrokes
it's like means like texture yeah and
then they texture it yeah it's just like
clear acrylic they love it that they
change the background even more dynamic
okay Wow who sent this to us
who said guys saw you needed a better
founders painting so I made one been a
huge fan of the show since the beginning
and it was a big influence on me getting
into visual effects and filmmaking I
thought this would be a perfect way to
give back to the show that inspired me
for so long
yes check out my work and your dildo
squarespace.com
you got Squarespace Andrew you got
Squarespace and you made us in our
founders painting we got to have this
guy over and shake his hand in front of
the painting well facing camera this is
the closest we've gotten to the dream so
far this is pretty incredible paintings
cool though it really makes it good
there's actually a story behind this
picture in the summer of 2008 Nico and
myself had just graduated from college
we were finishing up a short film my mom
was running a photography studio and was
like hey we should take a photo portrait
of you guys so this photo here was
actually featured in our hometown
Stillwater Gazette funny thing is
actually I just received that newspaper
last night so I should remember my mom
sent it to me she said oh I found this
also I really total coincidence I don't
think she knows that this what maybe
I claimed this the first day I started
work in a corridor so I just said I will
always have a nerve gun I have a nerf
guns Jan is on his way over Janet is the
founder of the nerf game that we've been
playing for these couple of years here
basically when you go over to somebody's
house you nerf assault them he is going
to nervous all us when he arrives in
about 15 minutes we thought about
setting up a nerf mine but the problem
is there's other people coming over also
you guys like my production meeting
setting traps on people that come a
professional production meeting is not
the best look
the one time Ren betrayed us betrayed us
three times he's the guy in the castle
that goes and opens a tiny door to
lettin that enemy it's like behind your
walls and then you'll walk in the first
things going on behind him we got it
froze man it's treason then to the roof
I'm gonna stay down here fighting let's
have a face time on the front there so
we can watch and see what he's coming in
and just hide the phone but you're going
on the roof dude hope you got to hold
your fire though yeah we're gonna sell
this bike in here what a horrible day
the aperture Cove 300 D the best part
brand-new so this is the older model
smaller twice the size so that's the
longest ballast I've ever seen watch
your back is that part of it too with
these lights and a proper camera we
don't need to get like giant hm eyes for
light huge fields and stuff like
literally with this and modern camera
technology we can film like night
sequences and scenes that otherwise
would have had insane amounts of
expenses and crew and like size and
lights and stuff that's not feasible for
like an independent film or a filmmaker
this is super cool great this is twice
the power output twice the size these
are great if you're doing stuff with
like a phantom doing like super slow
motion 10,000 frames per second it's
also really good if you have light
sensitive cameras and you just want to
just splash huge area with light at
night or something like that something
where you want mm yeah you want to fake
moonlight or something like that yeah
only go to 100 if you're plugged into
the wall otherwise always stay under 90
yeah let's do both at the same time
perfect
wait 100 it's brighter surprise that's a
good life I realize why aperture sure
makes the best lights aperture sure make
some good lights we do what what is that
this is an open but don't I have not
opened this but all I see is this on the
wall
this is another but this way this is on
the label pretty sweet like you think
it's a banner oh my god there may be
real this might be a paintings this this
just came in today this one to James
Bailey CEO quarter different is this a
dream
[Applause]
this is actually painted this is
actually painted this is like 1.2 times
scale it's so we need to get an ornate
gold frame for this James Bailey this is
so big there's so many points because of
the scale and also the fact that it's
real but then there's there I kind of
have to deduct bones points for adding
text over it the dream is still alive I
would be curious to see if it could get
better
I'm just saying I'm just a team are a
dream is still alive look at that look
at that our founder it's all shiny I
want to drink some whiskey this is like
what you put up on here you're fancy
like behind your fancy desk you put that
in the library you know next to the
fireplace this is like the grand
although this is bathroom facing toilet
sure I feel about this 500 years from
now this could be a hanging in the
museum yeah someone someone's gonna find
this ceiling in the apocalypse where
they keep where they kings over they men
yeah you gotta have your fun yeah a
front camera 5 you talk to you oh yeah
I'm gonna meet the audience
it works we got a security camera don't
you want to be here like where he is and
I could do it also from the mailbox to
the power box with his team enter you
might have enough time you put it on the
mailbox it'd be really funny he's gonna
be slaughtered over there
part of me kind of looks that happens I
am worried I'm watching waiting
what's up Carmichael chemicals on the
roof right now I gave us advance warning
I can't handle the pressure
Niko just I need one Dart no we're all
gonna see movement there he is he's
making sure he's like this we're all
prepared I don't think that counts we
filming our
we have this whole thing set up down
here we'd like to clear my shot it was
too easy
security of you solemnly walking inside
yeah it is actually incredibly possible
if you get like a smoking jacket